qui trouvez vous la plus belle marilyn
monroe le sex symbol hollywoodien des
années 1950 à la sensualité généreuse où
kate moss l'icône de mode des années 90
surnommée la brindille donnez moi votre
opinion dans les commentaires ce que
montre la différence entre ces deux
femmes admirés pour leur beauté que
seuls quelques dizaines d'années
séparent c'est que les repères
esthétique changent avec le temps la
beauté elle aussi aurait donc une
histoire je suis romain et vous êtes sur
mille îles et de culture générale
[Musique]
j'ai lu ce livre l'histoire de la beauté
de georges vigarello qui est un
historien et sociologue français
spécialiste du corps il y montre comment
la conception de la beauté a épousé
forcément les grandes dynamiques
sociales et rupture culturelle les
conflits de genres et de générations
il fait commencer l'histoire de la
beauté au xvième siècle parce que c'est
à ce moment que s'accélère la mutation
des repères esthétique et vous verrez à
la fin de la vidéo
l'ampleur des changements qui sont
intervenus en quelques siècles seulement
si j'avais une vidéo d'une femme de
xvième siècle et si je l'avais comparé à
kate moss
ça aurait été quelque chose allez je
vous en parle de cette femme du 16e
siècle
[Musique]
c'est donc la première beauté moderne
qui émerge au xvième siècle notamment
grâce aux artistes de la renaissance qui
décrivent le corps de manière plus
réaliste et qui sélectionnent leurs
modèles de plus en plus en fonction de
leur beauté
il y a trois éléments caractéristiques
de la beauté à retenir pour cette
période
vous allez voir qu'ils vont fortement
évolué avec les siècles
première chose la beauté est bien c'est
exclusivement la beauté de la femme
malgré son infériorité sociale la belle
femme est un idéal c'est pourquoi elle
est souvent comparée à une divinité
surtout vénus la déesse romaine de la
beauté l'homme lui est associé à des
qualités qui ne relèvent pas de
l'esthétique comme la force la dureté la
pilosité la fermeté la solidité qualité
qui sont toutes opposées à la prétendue
mollesse féminine
deuxième chose à retenir toutes les
parties du corps ne compte pas autant
dans la beauté loin de là en fait il y a
à l'époque une hiérarchie dans le corps
les parties hautes tout particulièrement
le le visage jusqu'à la gorge sont les
plus importantes
ce sont elles qui font la beauté donc
elles peuvent être découvertes le bas en
revanche n'est qu'un support un socle il
est donc inutile de le mettre en valeur
au 16ème siècle les jambes des femmes
sont occultés par des robes à évasement
et ils sortent du cadre des portraits en
clair les jambes ne compte pas
quel dommage troisième élément important
la beauté est indéfinissable
on n'a pas les mots pour la décrire avec
précision
on reste dans le vague on la contemple
comme une évidence comme si elle n'avait
pas besoin d'être pansées c'est surtout
la religion en fait qui impose sa
conception de la beauté
la femme ne doit pas user de son charme
esthétique pour séduire l'homme car sa
beauté consiste en des qualités morales
elle doit rester modeste humble et
chaste pas de quoi faire une couverture
de magazine
elle peut éventuellement se maquiller si
ça l'aide à trouver un mari
mais dans 99% des circonstances pas de
maquillage parce que c'est l'oeuvre du
diable alors petite conclusion partielle
pour ce siècle
la belle femme un beau visage blanc bien
symétrique
elle est très sérieuse mais elle est
déjà un peu plus pulpeuse que les
modèles du moyen-age on se rapproche de
marilyn monroe mais tout doucement
[Musique]
bien évidemment les choses ne changent
pas du tout au tout d'un siècle à
l'autre
donc il ya une certaine continuité la
dimension sociale de la beauté perdure
les nobles valorise minceur qui
symboliserait leur rectitude tandis que
les gens du peuple son rond parce qu'il
serait moralement trop relâché les
stéréotypes des sexes perdurer également
et l'artifice notamment le maquillage
est toujours comme sous le coude un
anathème avec la contre-réforme c'est
même un peu la mode d'abandonner
ostensiblement le maquillage en signe de
retour à la dévotion
alors malgré cette continuité
l'expérience esthétique elle change la
culture citadine rend la beauté plus
quotidienne plus sociale on paraît dans
les lieux de promenade pour se jauger
donc les repères de l'étiquette et du
maintien prennent de l'importance
l'idée sous jacente à cette évolution
c'est que la beauté exprimer l'identité
intérieur où l'âme si on veut un bon
visage est très vif et animé et il est
d'autant plus que le regard réussi à
transmettre quelque chose à produire une
émotion cette nouvelle idée
la beauté comme reflet de l'âme perpétue
la dimension mystérieuse de la beauté ce
je ne sais quoi qui la rend troublantes
les vieilles catégories morales sont
abandonnés au profit d'une typologie
psychologique de la beauté les beautés
sévère les beautés fier etc
d'où par exemple la mode du portrait
écrit qui consiste à mêler le physique
et le moral
cette importance nouvelle des patients
explique le prestige grandissant du
théâtre et la sensibilité des
spectateurs au charme de l'actrice mais
en même temps la conception de la beauté
est un peu désenchanté par la théorie
cartésienne du corps comme machine cette
théorie popularise des dispositifs
préventifs tels le corset qui comprime
les membres et ont malheureusement
beaucoup d'effets indésirables sur le
dos la respiration la laine etc
en gros on essaie de réparer le corps
comme on répare est une machine et grâce
à cette vision est bien
l'artifice gagne un peu plus en
légitimité
si le maquillage et réservés aux
occasions mondaine
il est proscrit pour les veuves les
vieilles femmes et plus globalement dans
le privé il s'est quand même imposé
alors comment décrire la belle femme du
xviie siècle elle a le regard plus
expressifs elle se montre davantage et
elle est probablement un peu plus
apprêtée c'est à partir du siècle
suivant que le corps commence à prendre
plus de place dans les repères
esthétique
le siècle des lumières est celui d'une
évolution fondamentale
c'en est fini du fantasque d'une beauté
unique
comme révélé par les dieux le sensible
et le caractère fonctionnel du corps
humains deviennent désormais primordiaux
dans le jugement esthétique le beau
corps est désormais regarder analyser
disséquer avec une débauche de critères
empirique est le plus important de ces
critères c'est la fonction naturelle de
la beauté
elle favorise le plaisir individuel en
vue de la perpétuation de l'espèce
cette idée sera notamment évoquée par
schopenhauer dans sa métaphysique de
l'amour
à propos de laquelle j'ai fait une vidéo
vous pouvez la voir en cliquant sur le
lien en haut à droite
la beauté exprimerait donc à l'échelle
individuelle une injonction de la nature
comme le dit voltaire la beauté pour un
crapaud et bien c'est simplement ça
crapaud d' avec ses deux gros yeux ronds
sa gueule et son ventre jaune de
crapauds de ça ne va pas plus loin
chez les humains on est surtout en
valeur les hanches qui renvoie à la
fonction gestatrice de la femme
cette pensée esthétique des lumières à
plusieurs applications
premièrement la beauté quotidienne est
plus libre
les artifices qui s'opposait au
développement naturel du corps sont
dénoncés les corsets ne sont plus
utilisés pour les enfants et leur
rigidité est atténuée pour les femmes
deuxième implication on considère
désormais que le corps doit être non
plus préservées mais stimulé
naturellement par exemple en favorisant
les influences atmosphérique le climat a
l'air l'eau ou avec des soins aquatique
pour densifier les fip plus généralement
par l'exercice physique comme les
promenades et dizzy
nick troisième implication de la pensée
esthétique des lumières le beau corps
c'est pour ressort notamment le corps
sain du paysan ou du sauvage a reposé au
corps a dégénéré du citadin en
conclusion partielle
la belle femme du xviiie siècle à des
formes plus maternelle et en même temps
elle est plus actif
une évolution qui commence à
transparaître également c'est la
dimension individualiste de l'esthétique
la beauté est de moins en moins un idéal
absolu lc personnalise elle devient le
moyen par exemple avec la coiffure qui
se développe d'exprimer une identité
singulière
[Musique]
l'évolution fondamentale de ce siècle et
que la beauté féminine devient plus
anatomique la perspective du siècle
passé
la nature est toujours là la tension
cambrure est la chute des reins renvoie
à la fécondité mais les lignes du corps
sont regardez plus dans le détail les
femmes les ausculte dans le miroir ou
dans les cabinets de gains
le revêtement les met davantage en
valeur ou plutôt les dissimule mans dans
le dernier quart du siècle par exemple
c'est la mode des robes collante qui
affirment les hanches les corses elles
deviennent beaucoup plus souple ils ne
font désormais plus qu assister la
fermeté anatomique féminine en misant
sur une forme corporelle en s et il ya
même carrément des mouvements d'opinion
qui dénonce le corps c'est notamment
parce qu'il n'est pas du tout adaptée
aux nouveaux métiers féminins des
métiers de bureaux sur tout mais surtout
la hiérarchisation des parties du corps
évoluent les partis baas d'elle le
bassin et la mort ceux des cuisses sont
de plus en plus prises en compte
du coup la beauté féminine devient plus
érotique
les actrices sont de plus en plus
sensuelle et provocante comme dans le
nana de zola
le nu se normalise à la fin du siècle
dans les spectacles les affiches et les
journaux enfin autre vecteur de
l'érotisme féminin les vacances à la
plage influencer les canons de beauté en
les américanisé
parallèlement les stéréotypes des
siècles passés recul
l'esthétique féminine intègre un
fantasme de liberté comme en témoigne la
figure de la parisienne de la première
moitié du siècle à vide d'exercice et
affirmant à laquelle on reproche
toutefois d'emprunter des qualités
masculin al'inverse l'homme lui sa douce
y un peu on lui demande désormais de
mêler la grâce à la vigueur
c'est même à cette époque qu émerge en
angleterre le modèle du dandy qui
incarne avec stremme lui qui soigne
profondément son apparence la nouvelle
combinaison masculine de force et
délicatesse les stéréotypes à l'encontre
des moyens d'embellissement recule aussi
les artifices sont désormais diffusés à
grande échelle comme si chacun avait un
droit à la beauté en 1859 baudelaire au
point un nouveau mot maquillage qu'il
assimile à un art un spectacle
mystérieux c'est en effet devenue une
architecture savantes où se combinent
les couleurs les couches et les niveaux
sur le plan économique se constitue un
véritable marché de l'embellissement
avec des produits de beauté et des soins
beauté sur différencier par les marques
promues agressivement par la publicité
qui mobilise ambassadrice des vedettes
et vendu en masse dans les grands
magasins
dépeint par zola dans au bonheur des
dames seulement tout le monde ne peut
pas encore s'offrir ces produits mais le
pouvoir de la mode est si grand que
certaines femmes vont jusqu'à se
prostituer pour s'offrir une paire de
gants ce marché de l'embellissement
ce sont aussi les régimes qui se
multiplient les instituts de beauté de
plus en plus nombreux et les débuts de
la chirurgie esthétique
alors comment décrire la belle femme du
19e siècle elle est beaucoup plus
érotique est là la poitrine galbées les
fesses rebondies et une chevelure
travail et qui nourrit les fantasmes
mais effet tout de même attention à la
minceur du bas du corps on est tout
proche de la beauté de marilyn monroe
comme ils sont encore en bonne partie
les nôtres on devine bien mieux les
repères esthétique des démocraties
contemporaines
ils sont le résultat de quatre
évolutions majeures
la première est le développement du
culte de la minceur qui exprime en fait
pour georges vigarello la pression
sociale à l'efficacité et à la
flexibilité la silhouette féminine idéal
a vraiment changé dans les années 1910
1920 la belle femme est dorénavant plus
grande plus étirés légère gracile mêmes
muscles et pour atteindre cet idéal
il faut bien sûr prendre régulièrement
des mesures
c'est pourquoi les mensurations
envahissent les magazines et les traiter
de poté à partir des années 1930 le
poids idéal baisse très rapidement
51 kg en 1939 contre 60 kg en 1929 pour
une femme d'un mètre soixante donc ça
fait moins 10 kg en seulement dix ans
enfin le culte de la minceur a aussi
paradoxalement une dimension hédoniste
avec le bronzage qui devient une mode
il ya même des machines élevé dès les
années 1930 ou encore avec les concours
de beauté qui se multiplient dans
l'entre-deux-guerres
la deuxième évolution majeure de la
période
c'est l'apparition de puissants modèles
esthétiques les stars le cinéma
notamment hollywoodien décuple le charme
de l'actrice qui avait émergé au cours
des siècles précédents
la photogénie terme inventé dans les
années 1920 et donc une nouvelle qualité
prix mondial de la beauté
les films montrent un visage
parfaitement maquillée avec des yeux qui
s'agrandissent à l'infini et des cheveux
d'une blondeur est insolente à la
lumière les actrices des années 50-60
suscite le désir du spectateur en
érotisant de nouvelles parties du corps
les lèvres entrouvertes et renflée la
poitrine ont répondu
comme brigitte bardot par exemple qui
jouent des femmes les affranchis et
provocante
si les stars sont des modèles
inaccessible leur exemple et leur
parcours inspirant même temps un rêve
esthétique social de masse en fait
l'exemple des stars diffuse la
conviction que la beauté récompense la
discipline la culture physique et le
régime or cette conviction érige le
corps en objet de consommation le marché
de l'embellissement se développe et la
production s'industrialise les
recherches se multiplient et décale les
efforts en 1930 le magazine vogue
déclare la cellulite qui a été
découverte seulement 1920 ennemi public
numéro 1 à la même époque n'est une
chirurgie purement esthétique
même si elles servent surtout à corriger
les rides ça représente 80% des
opérations 1930
mais la discipline va se développer et
se démocratiser si bien que 6% des
femmes françaises avaient déjà eu
recours à la chirurgie esthétique en
2000 surtout pour la liposuccion le
business de la beauté bénéficie de la
multiplication des médiums une femme sur
deux achète des magazines en 1981 de
telle sorte que deux sur trois en lice
le mannequinat se développe pour
accompagner la massification du marché
des artifices dont le volume est
multipliée plusieurs fois dans la
seconde partie du siècle
la dernière évolution majeure de la
période
c'est le bouleversement des genres
l'érotisation de l'esthétique féminine
n'est plus anodine elle s'accompagne de
la libération progressive de la femme
dans sa vie intime et dans ses choix
personnels
il ya en même temps une mutation
esthétique la belle femme des années
1980 prend dès 13 ans d'origine ses
formes sexuée les hanches et ce1 sont
gommées comme la mannequin française est
géré de chamelle inès de la fressange ou
encore kate moss dont j'ai parlé tout au
début mais la beauté masculine subi une
évolution comparable
assumant des traits féminins l'homme de
la fin du xxème siècle et 10
métrosexuels georges vigarello de nos
exemple le personnage de neo dans le
film matrix qui est un corps très beau
feeling alors que sa partenaire
trinity est elle plutôt masculine il
évoque aussi le visage lisse de david
beckham dépourvu d aspérités qui
symbolisait autrefois la dureté
masculine c'est dans une certaine mesure
la culture gay qui a contribué à
transposer au masculin
les repères esthétique et les artifices
féminin au total l'égalité a fait de la
beauté une qualité aussi masculine que
féminine le thème du beau sexe disparaît
mais surtout un seuil crucial a été
imperceptiblement franchi le bas du
corps compte désormais plus que le haut
les repères esthétiques ont donc
profondément évolué depuis la
renaissance
comment retenir en synthèse je crois que
trois évolutions sont particulièrement
fondamentale la première c'est que la
totalité du corps a été progressivement
prise en compte dans la beauté et que la
hiérarchie originelle s'est même
inversée
même si le visage compte toujours la
deuxième évolution c'est la libération
des codes de l'apparence l'individu peut
désormais les déterminé par lui-même les
vieux stéréotypes ont disparu les
repères sont très émietté l'individu
peut adopter une esthétique plus ou
moins féminine ou masculine faire son
choix parmi les multiples modèles
disponibles qui change sans cesse de
look qui viennent cinéma du sport de la
téléréalité et maintenant des réseaux
sociaux
enfin la troisième évolution liés à la
seconde c'est que la beauté n'est plus
un destin mais un projet
les modèles qui détermine les repères
des icônes d'hollywood yens modèle
d'instagram entretiennent une émulation
esthétique qui balancent l'individu
contemporain entre l'épanouissement et
la crispation qu'on pense à l'incroyable
paradoxe des régimes alors qu'ils sont
très populaires
ils sont statistiquement vouée à l'échec
moins de 40% réussissent à court moyen
terme et moi 2 25% à long terme c'est à
dire au delà de cinq ans pourquoi
l'individu persiste-t-il alors le fin
mot de l'histoire c'est que la démarche
esthétique est en réalité une quête
d'identité trouver et construire sa
beauté c'est pour l'individu moderne se
trouver soi-même
[Musique]
si vous avez aimé la vidéo donnez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la
suivante si vous voulez lire mon article
de blog tiré de la lecture de ce livre
l'histoire de la beauté de georges
vigarello ou même si vous voulez lire ce
livre directement tous les liens sont
dans la description et enfin pour
recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisée dans le format le
plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous abonner à ma newsletter
en laissant votre adresse mail sur le
site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur
milliers de culture générale n'oubliez
pas de vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser aux
meilleurs de la possible
[Musique]